do you know about the Michelin it is a  book it is the book Jana the Bible  Mishler sense it's inspectors to  restaurants to eat and watch stars one  two three or none no one knows who they  are no one they come they eat they go  but they have hobbits they have to stick  to a routine to give every restaurant  the same chance I think I scratched it  my turn you're no stranger to criminal  law Jim look at the situation the man is  publicly reviled and I will be too yes  in more ignorant quarters but that's  exactly why this has to be done and  capably done it can't look like our  justice system tosses people on the a  sheep  right let's do the math our service  mission here was supposed to last 31  Sol's for redundancy they sent 68 Sol's  worth of food that's 46 people so for  just me that's gonna last 300 Sol's  which I figure I can stretch to 400 if I  ration so I got to figure out a way to  grow three years worth of food here